[Applaudissements]
j'ai créé mon entreprise innovante et je
souhaiterais commencer par partager avec
vous une petite histoire que
j'affectionne c'est l'histoire paysans
qui décide d'aller s'acheter des chevaux
ils achètent tous des chevaux noirs sauf
un qui achètent un cheval blanc alors
tous les paysans propriétaires de
chevaux noirs ils vont voir un dépaysant
jo et 10 à djoum il regarde il a de la
chance lui il a un cheval blanc et nous
on a des cheveux noirs et jo il dit
peut-être bien qu'oui peut-être bien que
non
et puis décide de partir en balade à
cheval
le cheval blanc et un peu plus fougueuse
et un moment ils cabre le paysan tombe
se casse la jambe
eva boiter avis tous les paysans
retourne voir joe et dix jours où tu
avais raison
heureusement qu'on a des cheveux noirs
et joy dit peut-être bien qu'oui
peut-être bien que non et puis arrive la
guerre et tous les paysans sont
réquisitionnés pour partir à la guerre
sauf celui qui est un cheval blanc et
donc il retourne voir jo il a de la
chance et deux jours répond peut-être
bien qu'oui peut-être bien que non
alors comment savoir si un choix est bon
comment savoir si un choix est parfait
existe-t-il un choix parfait
aujourd'hui on sort diplômé on a
plusieurs possibilités aller travailler
dans un grand groupe allait travailler
dans une petite structure monter sa
boîte allait faire le tour du monde
allez dans l'humanitaire faire une
formation complémentaire est ce que
c'est le bon choix
peut-être bien qu'oui peut-être bien que
non moi j'ai eu mon grand père atteint
de la maladie d'alzheimer et j'ai décidé
à un moment de me lancer dans la
création d'entreprise
j'ai fait un choix ou des cours de
l'union j'ai fait un choix où je suis
devenu ceinture noire de tous qu'il faut
pas faire c'est à dire que j'ai fait le
choix de d'innover dans un marché en
créations qu'on commence à appeler
aujourd'hui de m'acheter de la silver
economy marché des personnes âgées
j'ai fait un choix de faire du logiciel
en même temps fait de l'électronique
puisqu'on a un petit boîtier pour
transformer la télé en plateforme de
services pour la personne âgée
on a fait un choix de vendre en ce qu'on
appelle be to be to see donc à faire un
double marketing pour pouvoir vendre etc
etc
était ce le bon choix
peut-être bien qu'oui peut-être bien que
non et je souhaiterais partager avec
vous quelques principes que j'ai pu
apprendre retirer de cette expérience et
que je crois applicables à la vie de
tous les jours
tout d'abord je voudrais casser le
principe l'idée qu'on nous dit que c'est
l'idée qui compte c'est l'idée qui fait
l'entreprise
pas du tout l'idée c'est la base
important derrière c'est d'écouter de
corriger de se tromper de refaire
jusqu'à petit à petit et bien que cette
idée se transforme en entreprise pour
vous donner un exemple dans mes premiers
rendez vous avec les fonds
d'investissement
j'expliquais voilà une personne âgée
toutes les études démontrent
le plus important c'est sortir de la
solitude sortir de l' isolement un
smartphone avant d'être smart et les
faunes c'est le lien social qui est
hyper important donc nous on va
commencer par travailler le lien social
et puis je continuer et puis je moi il
m'a fallu quelques rendez vous pour voir
que la tension tomber dès ses premières
phrases et de comprendre pour corriger
que voilà pour un investisseur sociale
ça veut plutôt dire il ya pas d'argent
donc je n'investis pas et donc j'ai
corrigé le deuxième point c'est qu'il
faut oser quand on est petit on se pose
pas la question je suis à quatre pattes
mais je vais oser marché je me casse la
figure je réessaie cette figure jusqu'à
ce que j'arrive à marcher je veux faire
du vélo je me pose pas non plus voilà
j'essaye je rate je réessaye et j'y
arrive quand on est plus grand il ya
mille et une vraie bonne raison de ne
pas faire parce qu'on cherche souvent à
essayer de tout verrouiller que ce soit
un projet certes imparfait et donc je
vous invite à oser parce que vous verrez
plus on n'ose plus on est fiers et plus
on ose
ensuite je vous invite à définir des
objectifs et à tracer votre sillon celui
qui n'a pas d'objectif ne risque pas de
les atteindre dans le secteur quand on
parle des personnes âgées en ap trois
âges c'est vrai pour tout le monde
d'ailleurs on a l'âge chronologique
d'accord l'anniversaire on al'âge
psychologique c'est l'âge qu'on a dans
sa tête et on al'âge morphologiques là
jusqu'à notre corps on devient vieux non
pas par rapport à l'âge chronologique on
devient vieux par rapport à la jusqu'à
notre corps qu'on maîtrise pas mais anna
qu'il ya quelque chose qu'on maîtrise et
le côté psychologique c'est à dire qu on
devient vieux lorsqu'on n'a plus de
projet donc je vous invite à vous fixer
des objectifs à avoir des projets et à
tracer votre sillon c'est à dire être
têtu il m'a fallu dix ans pour que la
voilà on arrive à signer il ya de ça
quelques semaines avec le leader
européen des maisons de retraite
c'est un peu comme un marathon où la
saintélyon à venir s'il faut que dès le
début vous ayez la certitude que vous
allez terminer
sinon vous aurez plein de bonnes raisons
au mieux d'arrêter
ensuite il est de mon point de vue très
important d'arriver à gérer son énergie
l'énergie c'est comme la trésorerie le
cash d'une entreprise si on a plus ça
s'arrête
l'énergie on en a une quantité en début
de journée et puis dans la journée on a
des choses qui nous stresse on a des
choses qui nous on n'a pas envie de
faire qui nous prennent de l'énergie et
puis on a d'autres choses qui nous donne
du plaisir qui nous donne de la joie qui
nous donne de l'énergie
et l'objectif c'est qu'à la fin de la
journée on soit dans le vert et pas dans
le rouge et donc fait le tri et essayer
de prendre le plus possible ce qui vous
donne de l'énergie
c'est ce qui entre autres permet
d'éviter tout ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui burnout ou autre enfin est
probablement le plus important
je vous invite à définir vos valeurs
c'est une notion compliqués sont des
convictions
ce sont des choses qui donnent des
étoiles dans les yeux et c'est une
boussole
je reste convaincu voilà qu'on a plein
de valeurs mais qu'on en a trois
principales pour ma part c'est ce qui
m'a permis de franchir les tempêtes de
la création d'entreprises ces valeurs
elles sont propres à chacun donc elles
ne sont pas parfaites pour ma part c'est
voilà j'avais besoin de trouver un
travail avec un côté humain fort ont
travaillé que les personnes âgées
j'avais besoin d'innovation parce que
depuis qu'il est tout petit je construis
des trucs
voilà des est comment dire des fusées
les machins fait etc
et puis j'avais besoin de trouver un job
ou où je puisse sans prétention mais
avoir la possibilité que que ça puisse
se vendre à l'international
c'est ni bien ni mal c'est pas un
exemple ce sont mes valeurs monde
imperfections et vous voyez quand on a
défini ses trois valeurs
eh bien on voit que finalement on peut
les retrouver dans différents jobs
l'important c'est d'arriver voilà à
avoir cette boussole
alors je vous propose deux petits
exercices par rapport à ça le premier
c'est une question que je pose
systématiquement en entretien d'embauché
c'est quelle est la personne que vous
admirez le plus et pourquoi
là vous aurez trouvé une valeur quelque
chose qui vous met des étoiles dans les
yeux
le deuxième exercice qu'on peut faire
régulièrement
cette chaudière voilà la tient au moment
présent
si j'avais une note a donné entre un et
dix sur comment je me sens là quel est
mon et à l'intérieur quelle serait cette
note est là aussi
quand vous serez vers 9-10 et un truc
hein là aussi une valeur importante
voyez là pour moi je suis à sept
je suis hyper content d'être là hyper
content d'être devant vous et assez
stressé
je vous invite à innover je vous invite
à innover pour vous surprendre je vous
invite à innover pour vous trompez et
apprendre et je vous invite à innover
pour franchir vos sommet et atteindre
votre imperfections parce qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de perfection on essaie de
nous faire croire qu'il y à la
perfection
on essaie de nous nous insuffler par des
facebook ou autre une perfection mais ce
qui est beau et ce qu'il faut viser
c'est son imperfection
merci
[Applaudissements]